E
THEIR DECISION IS HEADED
TOWARDS, SO WE WILL WATCH THIS
VERY CLOSELY.
ALSO TONIGHT COMING UP, A
BOMBSHELL NEW DEVELOPER FROM THE
DURHAM PRO.
WE ALSO HAVE DISTURBING A VIDEO
SHOWING ALLEGED ANTIFA RIOTING
ATTACKING REPUBLICANS IN
PORTLAND.
BY THE WAY, POLICE TOOK FOREVER
TO GET THERE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
CELEBRATING A LOOMING FOOD
SHORTAGE THAT WOULD FORCE
AMERICA'S FARMERS TO "GO GREEN"
REALLY?
THAT'S THE NEXT INFLATION?
THAT'S THE NEXT HIKE ON GAS?
FOOD PRICES AREN'T HIGH ENOUGH?
ANYWAY, WE WILL ALSO WEIGH IN ON
JOE'S BIG WEEKEND IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
BY THE WAY, MY RECORD IS INTACT.
IN ALL THE YEARS I'VE BEEN ON
RADIO, 35 YEARS, 26 AND A HALF
YEARS AT FOX, I HAD NEVER BEEN
TO A SINGLE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENTS' DINNER, AND I
DID NOT BREAK THAT RECORD AND
SHOW UP THIS WEEKEND, AND I
NEVER WILL.
I KNOW THEY DON'T LIKE ME, I
DON'T PARTICULARLY LIKE THEM, SO
LET'S NOT PLAY GAMES.
ANYWAY.
THEY DID HAVE SOME FUN, GOOD, AT
OUR EXPENSE.
THAT'S ALSO GOOD.
AND SATURDAY'S WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENTS' DINNER, WE WILL
GIVE YOU AN UPDATE.
WE WANT TO INTRODUCE YOU TO A
NOT SO BRIGHT MSDNC HOST WAS
HAVING A REALLY HARD TIME COPING
WITH TWITTER'S NEW OWNERSHIP.
WE GO TO ONE OF THEIR HOSTS, I
DON'T REALLY KNOW THIS GUY, HIS
DANGEROUS NEO-NAZIS ARE NOW
POISED TO TAKE OVER THE COUNTRY
ALL BECAUSE ELON MUSK BOUGHT
TWITTER AND ELON MUSK IS SAYING
STAY ON TWITTER, ALL MY CRITICS
FEEL FREE TO ATTACK ME BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT FREE SPEECH IS ALL
ABOUT.
THEY ARE THAT UPSET?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE ARE LIVING THERE IN
UNSPEAKABLE DANGEROUS MOMENT.
THE PRO-HUMAN ON PRO-NEO-NAZI
FACTION IS POISED TO EXPAND
DRAMATICALLY AMONG THE MIDTERMS.
WE ARE JUST TWO YEARS AWAY FROM
DONALD TRUMP VERY POSSIBLY
RE-SEASONED EXECUTIVE POWER.
IF THAT HAPPENS WE MAY LOOK BACK
ON THIS PAST WEEK AS A PIVOTAL
MOMENT WHEN A PETULANT AND NOT
SO BRIGHT BILLIONAIRE CASUALLY
BOUGHT ONE OF THE WORLD'S MOST
INFLUENTIAL MESSAGING MACHINES
AND JUST HANDED IT TO THE FAR
RIGHT.
>> Sean: TODAY ELON MUSK
RESPONDED TWEETING OUT "NBC IS
BASICALLY SAYING REPUBLICANS
ARE."
BY THE WAY, I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'VE EVER WATCHED THE SHOW,
ARE YOU WATCHING TONIGHT?
EVERY SINGLE DAY, USED TO BE
EVERY TWO YEARS, EVERY FOUR
YEARS, NOW IT'S PRETTY MUCH
EVERY DAYS, OR REPUBLICANS ARE
RACIST, SEXIST, HOMOPHOBIC,
XENOPHOBIC, ISLAMOPHOBIC,
NONTRANSFERABLE.
THEY WANT DIRTY AIR AND WATER,
THEY WANT GRANDMA AND GRANDPA
ONLY TO EAT DOG AND CAT FOOD AND
THEN THEY WANT SOME PROMINENT
REPUBLICAN LOOK-ALIKE TO TAKE
GRANNY AND GRANDPA IN A
WHEELCHAIR AND THROW THEM OVER A
CLIFF.
WELCOME TO MY WORLD.
WELCOME TO THE WORLD OF
CONSERVATISM.
THIS IS THE SAME ORGANIZATION
THAT COVERED UP THE HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP, HE GOES ON, AND HAD THE
HARVEY WEINSTEIN STORY EARLY AND
THEY KILLED IT, AND THEY BUILT
MATT LAUER -- HE WROTE HIS
OFFICE AND HE'S TALKING ABOUT
THAT LOCK THING THAT HAD BEEN
REPORTED.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WAS EVER
VERIFIED.
LOVELY PEOPLE, HE WRITES.
ANYWAY, I'LL ADD THIS IS THE
SAME NETWORK THAT BRINGS YOU
JOY REID, CONSPIRACY THEORIST OF
ALL TIME RACHEL MADDOW, AND
UNTIL RECENTLY, LYING BRIAN
WILLIAMS, THE GUY THAT SAW DEAD
BODIES FLOATING DURING KATRINA
IN FRONT OF HIS HOTEL.
THAT WASN'T FLOODED.
NEEDLESS TO SAY, NBC NEWS
DOESN'T EXACTLY VALUE TRUTH.
NEITHER DOES FAKE NEWS CNN FOR
THAT MATTER.
BOTH ORGANIZATIONS ARE ONLY
PROPAGANDA ARMS FOR THE DNC.
A PETAL IN LIES AND CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, ALWAYS TO ADVANCE THE
SOCIALIST AGENDA, HATE ON
CONSERVATIVE -- EVERYTHING
CONSERVATIVE, AND TRUMP AND ALL
TRUMP SUPPORTER'S.
AND ON SUNDAY, ONE CNN GUEST
CALLED FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO STEP IN, REGULATE
DISCOURSE ON TWITTER BEFORE IT'S
TOO LATE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MUSK DOESN'T WANT -- YOU
KNOW, HE'S UPSET WITH THE SEC.
HOW DARE THEY QUESTION HIM.
THIS IS DANGEROUS.
WE CAN'T THINK ANYMORE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WE DON'T HAVE PEOPLE -- NO, I'M
SERIOUS, WE DON'T HAVE PEOPLE IN
CONGRESS WHO CAN MAKE
REGULATIONS, THAT CAN MAKE IT
WORK.
I THINK WE CAN LOOK TO THE
WESTERN COUNTRIES IN EUROPE FOR
HOW THEY ARE TRYING TO LIMIT IT,
BUT YOU NEED, YOU NEED CONTROLS
ON THIS.
YOU NEED REGULATION.
YOU CANNOT LET THESE GUYS
CONTROL DISCOURSE IN THIS
COUNTRY, OR WE ARE HEADED TO
HELL.
WE ARE THERE.
TRUMP OPENED THE GATES TO HELL
AND NOW THEY ARE CHASING US
DOWN.
>> Sean: WHERE WERE THESE
PEOPLE WERE DONALD TRUMP,
CONSERVATIVES BAND, SUSPENDED,
CANCELED, SHADOW BANNED, THIS IS
THE COMMON THEME ON THE LEFT,
IT'S CALLED HYPOCRISY, UNLIKE
MANY OF MY SO-CALLED
COMPETITORS, I'VE NEVER CALLED
FOR ANY SHOW OR ANY HOST OR ANY
GUEST BE CANCELED OR BOYCOTTED
OR CENSORED.
I BELIEVE IN FREE SPEECH.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE WHAT THEY SAY,
I HOPE YOU TUNE THEM OUT, MOST
AMERICANS ALREADY ARE.
BUT ACCORDING TO THEM, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU CAN'T BE
TRUSTED.
ONLY BIG MOTHER GOVERNMENT KNOWS
RIGHT FROM WRONG.
FOR EXAMPLE, WHILE MSDNC AND
FAKE NEWS CNN FREAK OUT ABOUT
ELON MUSK AND FREE SPEECH
ON TWITTER, ALL OF A SUDDEN --
IGNORED IT ALL THIS TIME, THEY
ARE ALL BUT APPLAUDING THE
HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY IN
HIS ANNOUNCEMENT --
PRONOUNCEMENT OF CREEPY NEW
DISINFORMATION GOVERNANCE BOARD,
OR AS WE CALL IT ON THE SHOW,
THE SOCIALIST DEMOCRATS MINISTER
OF LEFTIST TRUTH.
WATCH THIS.
>> IN THE U.S. THERE'S BEEN AN
UPROAR IN RECENT DAYS ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT FROM UNSECURED HE
SETTING UP WHAT THE COLOR
DISINFORMATION GOVERNANCE BOARD.
THIS IS BEEN MOSTLY OF FOX WORLD
STORY.
COME UP EARLY ON CNN'S STATE OF
THE UNION BUT IT DON'T THINK
PEOPLE KNOW WHAT IT IS AND WHAT
IT ISN'T AND IS JUST BEEN A LOT
OF RIGHT WING UPROAR WITHOUT
KNOWING WHAT IT IS.
>> Sean: KEEP IN MIND, THE
DHS, THEY WERE FOUNDED AFTER
9/11, WE LOST NEARLY 3,000 OF
OUR FELLOW AMERICANS.
THEY WERE DESIGNED TO PREVENT
ANOTHER 9/11, ANOTHER ATTACK ON
THE HOMELAND.
BUT UNDER SECRETARY MAYORKAS,
THE DEPARTMENT HAS NOW TURNED
THEIR FOCUS INWARD?
A COMPLETE DERELICTION OF DUTY,
A COMPLETE RETREAT FROM A
POST-9/11 WORLD AND POLICIES TO
KEEP EVERY AMERICAN IN THIS
COUNTRY SAFE FROM TERRORISTS.
BY THE WAY, HOW MANY TERRORIST
ENCOUNTERS DID THEY HAVE AT THE
BORDER?
41?
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW.
HOW MANY PEOPLE MIGHT HAVE SNUCK
IN THAT WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT?
AND ACCORDING TO HIM,
DISINFORMATION AND CLIMATE
CHANGE, THEY ARE THE CRISES OF
THE DAY, AND APPARENTLY WE HAVE
NO ONE TO BLAME BUT OURSELVES.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE
ADMINISTRATION ACTUALLY BELIEVES
THE GREATEST THREAT TO THIS
GREAT COUNTRY, WE, THE AMERICA
PEOPLE.
HOW TO LOOK INTO DOMESTIC
TERRORISM, THOSE SCARY MOMMIES
AND DADDIES AT SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS THAT WILL BE
INVESTIGATED FOR DOMESTIC
TERRORISM IF THEY DARE TO RAISE
THEIR VOICE AGAINST CRT OR AGE
INAPPROPRIATE EDUCATION.
AND COUNTER TO THIS GREAT
THREAT, HE ANNOUNCED A NEW
MINISTRY OF TRUTH TO BE LED BY A
FAR LEFT LUNATIC WHO IRONICALLY
SPREADS A TON OF DISINFORMATION
ALL THE TIME.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN APRIL OF 2020,
NINA JANKOWICZ REFERRED TO THE
COVID-19 LAB LEAK THEORY AS A
BASELESS RUMORS SPREAD BY TRUMP
SUPPORTER'S.
FALSE.
CHINESE STATE RUN MEDIA RECENTLY
CITED HER FICTITIOUS CLAIMS,
USING THEM IN THEIR OWN
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN.
AND JANKOWICZ ALSO MISSED SPREAD
INFORMATION PLAYING DOWN THE
HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP, SHE CALLED
THAT ANOTHER TRUMP PRODUCT.
ANOTHER DISINFORMATION LIE.
HE PRAISED DOSSIER AUTHOR
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND ON
TWITTER SHE ENTHUSIASTICALLY
VOICED HER SUPPORT FOR
HILLARY CLINTON AND ECHO
HILLARY'S INSANE CLAIM THAT
TRUMP WOULD EMBOLDEN ACES.
EVEN THOUGH HE ACTUALLY WIPES
THEM OFF THE PLANET AND SENT
THEM STRAIGHT TO HELL WHERE THEY
BELONG.
BUT DON'T WORRY, LET NOT YOUR
HEART BE TROUBLED, ACCORDING TO
HIM, OUR NEW DISINFORMATION
MINISTER IS TOTALLY NEUTRAL WITH
NO BIAS AT ALL.
WILL ONLY ACT IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF AMERICANS ON A
GOVERNMENT DISINFORMATION BOARD
THAT WILL NEVER ABUSE ITS POWER.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S SAYING.
DIDN'T THEY TELL US THAT WITH
FISA WARRANTS?
I THINK THEY DID VERY TAKE A
LOOK.
>> WILL AMERICAN CITIZENS BE
MONITORED?
>> NO.
>> GUARANTEE THAT?
>> WHAT WE DO, WE THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY DON'T
MONITOR AMERICAN CITIZENS.
>> YOU DON'T, BUT WILL THIS
BOARD CHANGE THAT?
>> NO, THE BOARD DOES NOT HAVE
ANY OPERATIONAL AUTHORITY OR
CAPABILITY.
WHAT IT WILL DO IS GATHER
TOGETHER BEST PRACTICES IN
ADDRESSING THE THREAT OF
DISINFORMATION FROM FOREIGN
STATE ADVERSARIES, FROM THE
CARTELS, AND DISSEMINATE THOSE
BEST PRACTICES TO THE OPERATORS
THAT HAVE BEEN EXECUTING AND
ADDRESSING THIS THREAT FOR
YEARS.
>> Sean: SO WE ARE SUPPOSED TO
TAKE HIS WORD FOR IT.
DIDN'T THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ALSO TELL US THAT THE PROGRAM
WOULD NEVER BE USED AGAINST
AMERICANS?
TELL THAT TO CARTER PAGE AND
DONALD J. TRUMP.
AND WHAT ABOUT THE SHOCKING
REPORT FROM LATE LAST WEEK
DETAILING HOW THE FBI ACTUALLY
WAS CAUGHT SEARCHING MILLIONS OF
EMAILS AND TEXTS AND OTHER
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATIONS OF
AMERICANS WITHOUT ANY WARRANT
WHATSOEVER.
THE LAST THING THIS COUNTRY
NEEDS IS YET ANOTHER GOVERNMENT
PROGRAM THAT GETS USED AND
ABUSED TO MONITOR AMERICANS